in this lesson we're going to talk about
the distance formula now the distance
formula is an important formula to know
for the a c t so let's go over the form
of the first and we'll do some examples
so the distance formula is
x 2 minus x 1 squared plus y 2 minus y 1
squared so what this means is you know
you add them together you take the
square root but what this means is you
know you've got your two points x1 y1
and your other point x2 y2 so all you're
doing is you're subtracting the x
coordinates okay of the two points and
then squaring subtracting the y
coordinates of the two points squaring
you add those two quantities together
and then you take the square root so you
want to follow the order of operations
let's go through some examples see if
you can do these on your own and we'll
go through them together so the first
one we're trying to find the distance
between the point 3 4
and 8 16. so if you want you can label
this x1 y1
and x2
y2 and all we're going to do is we're
going to substitute these values into
the formula so
let's go ahead and do that so we've got
the square root of
8 minus
squared so x minus x plus
16 minus
4. so y2 minus y1 squared we're going to
add those together and take the square
root so 8 minus 3 is 5 squared plus 16
minus 4 is 12 squared and then if we
simplify this we get 5 squared is 25
12 squared is 144 and the square root of
equals 13. so the distance between the
two points is 13. okay see if you can do
example number two
it says what is the distance between
negative one four and seven
negative eleven okay so same idea take
the square root we've got
7 minus negative 1. now you want to be
careful with these negatives when you
subtract a negative it's like adding the
opposite right
and then we've got a negative 11 minus 4
squared so this is going to be 8 squared
plus
negative 15 squared
add those together we get 64 plus 225
add those together that's 289 and the
square root of 289 is 17. so the
distance between these two points is 17.
so definitely an important formula to
memorize and know for the act the
distance formula i'll see in the next
lesson